parmi les aubert je rappelle que vous
êtes donc chargé de communication à la
maison de l'environnement de magny les
hameaux
on passe maintenant à la semaine du
développement durable qui va débuter
mardi prochain le 2 avril
c'est un événement national je le
rappelle je je le rappelle la
programmation est très riche très variés
à qui se destine ce type d'événement
alors nous à la comité d'agglomération
aux fêtes de saint quentin en yvelines a
choisi justement de programmer une
semaine du développement durable pour
tous les publics donc il y en a pour
tout le monde
autant les familles les enfants les
écoles mais aussi les professionnels et
pourquoi pas même les élus également
pour pouvoir s'informer sur ces
thématiques
justement comment les élus sont
impliqués alors là nous on va plutôt en
fait les sensibiliser à travers des
ateliers débats du code skis plutôt sur
justement ce qui est des placements se
déplacer écologique mais aussi par le
biais justement de l'agencé locale de
l'énergie et du climat qui accompagne la
communauté d'agglomération dans son plan
de développement durable mais quand même
une grosse thématique sur
l'écoconstruction j'ai retenu quelques
dates
n'en jetez plus et habiter écologique
oui une grosse exposition atelier qui
est conçue par la cité de l'architecturé
du patrimoine qui étaient conçus à
quelques années qui présentait à paris
un grand succès et donc le conseil
général des yvelines a choisi justement
de la mettre en itinérance dans
différents lieux de des yvelines et la
maison d'environnement a la chance de
l'accueillir à partir de samedi prochain
c'est pas une exposition comme toutes
les autres c'est vraiment une exposition
atelier avec une exposition interactive
où on a représenté un peu les différents
lieux de la maison avec des objets du
quotidien pour lesquels on va pouvoir
apprendre à faire de réels et qu il est
de réelles économies en tout cas au
niveau des factures qu'on d'accord il ya
aussi un jeu de l'oie géant plus belle
la ville
un atelier qui a été créée par le musée
de la ville est donc proposé à la maison
de l'environnement dans le cadre de la
semaine du développement durable
c'est un jeu de société géant pour les
enfants qui vont qui va permettre en
fait de mieux comprendre comment on doit
concevoir une ville dite durable avec
des écoquartiers la place de la
biodiversité les transports les écoles
voilà à travers un jeu amusant et
ludique et un atelier ma maison et qu'on
construit donc c'est des maquettes c'est
ça alors pas tout à fait ce sont en fait
donc ce sera l' agence locale de
l'énergie et du climat qui va proposer
aux enfants d'étudier justement les
différentes façons de penser son habitat
dans le monde
on ne dépense pas de la même façon que
l'on habite en antarctique ou bien dans
le désert au sud saharien voilà on est
vraiment des habitats très différents
donc comprendre pourquoi et comment il
faut orienter son habitat différemment
et donc là on va effectivement
construire soi même une maison mais en
fonction cette fois ci des ressources
qu'il y ait en ile-de-france le vent le
soleil l'inclinaison et c'est donc on va
voilà on va parler d'habitat ce moment
d'accord il ya aussi beaucoup de métiers
qui se développe autour de l'éco
construction
tout à fait c'est les métiers du btp
effectivement qui sont vraiment en
grande émergence et la cité des métiers
de saint quentin divine justement
propose une journée alors en matinée
avec justement une rencontre des
professionnels du domaine du btp de
l'éco-construction et puis en après midi
des visites de bâtiments exemplaires
pour montrer justement voilà comment on
peut mettre l'écologie dans les
bâtiments et la maison de
l'environnement fait quoi par exemple
dans le développement durable
elle programme d action et de
sensibilisation pour le tout public
justement dans participé à la semaine du
développement durable entre autres en
fait on est vraiment un lieu
d'information et de sensibilisation sur
cette thématique là d'accord alors je
rappelle que cette semaine et national
sur le développement durable et la db
elle est adaptée dans plusieurs communes
comme les clayes-sous-bois où on pourra
découvrir lors d'une conférence comment
devenir un éco consommateurs elle est
signée elle est sous le signe du pardon
de la transition énergétique donc c'est
là que vous intervenez johan girbaud
telle transition
merci quelles sont les missions de votre
agence locale de l'est
j ai du climat alors nos missions en
fait sont d'accompagner les particuliers
et les collectivités locales sur tout ce
qui est questionnement en termes de
maîtrise de l'énergie et de
développement des énergies renouvelables
dans ce cadre notamment on tient ce
qu'on appelle une permanence info
énergie dans nos locaux et à la
médiathèque du canal à 5 ans à
montigny-le-bretonneux auprès des
particuliers pour les renseigner et les
conseillers de manière objective et
gratuite sur tout ce qui est la question
de comment mieux isoler ma maison
comment développer l'énergie solaire sur
mon toit ou ce genre de choses il refait
des sens justement des personnes qui
s'intéressent à ces économies d'énergie
alors oui tout à fait principalement en
hiver bien entendu quand ils se rendent
compte que le chauffage leur coûte de
plus en plus cher on a une vraie celle
on a des vrais science ouais c'est le
moment de prise de conscience exactement
donc on a une vraie prise de conscience
à ce moment là et les gens se posent ces
questions là à ce moment là puis
viennent quand même malgré tout aussi
nous voir tout au long de l'année parce
qu'on était c'est là où on peut faire
les travaux donc il se pose ces
questions là aussi à ce moment là
d'accord et dans la semaine du
développement durable vous allez animer
organiser des événements particuliers
alors oui on va faire
une visite d'une maison bbc construite
en monomur donc d'abaisser c'est maison
basse consommation en fait c'est un
niveau de performance énergétique
important c'est le niveau réglementaire
aujourd'hui mais seulement depuis le 1er
janvier de cette année donc c'est une
maison qui est construite en monomur et
qui est située à toussus-le-noble donc
j'invite les gens à se rapprocher de nos
services pour pouvoir s'inscrire
on va également organiser donc avec la
mairie de voisins-le-bretonneux une
animation sur la thermographie aérienne
puisque une thermographie aérienne a été
réalisé et un débat sur la transition
énergétique
le 5 avril au soir le vendredi 5 avril
au soir
et donc tous les citoyens de saint
quentin en yvelines sont invités à venir
proposer leur apporter leur pique leurs
propositions concernant comment on peut
faire la transition énergétique au
niveau national et tout ça malgré les
crises c'est à dire que malgré la crise
malgré les investissements difficile
aussi parce que même si ça permet de
faire des économies il faut quand même
sortir le budget aussi au départ pour
investir sur les panneaux solaires et
autres les gens s'y intéressent toujours
fonds d'investissement réussissent à
même malgré tout trouver les noms voilà
en termes de conseil il ya de plusieurs
niveaux de conseil a déjà le premier
niveau de conseil qui et comment arriver
à améliorer les choses sans se faire
d'investissement est ce qu'on appelle la
sobriété énergétique et donc ça c'est
primordial c'est la première chose et
ensuite une fois qu'on arrive à
expliquer aux gens que par des petits
investissements ou par des
investissements moyens ils arriveront à
faire des économies sur le moyen terme
on arrive à faire précéder le début fin
en tout cas obligé de se ruiner sur les
débutants tout à fait d'accord c'était
un conseil important très bien pas tout
à fait et je précise que trois journées
seront dédiés à l'énergie
c'est sans fin de semaine oui tout à
fait vous allez organiser un accueil
particulier pour les personnes alors en
fait on va continuer notre accueil
particulier met donc sur ces journées là
on va augmenter le nombre de prises de
rendez-vous si nécessaire que l'on peut
accorder dans nos dans nos locaux très
bien merci à tous les deux la chronique
de l'environnement à présent c'est avec
la journée oui alors une date à retenir
c'est aujourd'hui ce soir 20h15 au
cinéma
roxane de versailles faut courir pour
aller assister à une soirée débat sur le
gaz de schiste en présence de brigitte
boucher physicienne et chercheuse au
cnrs et membre du collectif citoyen
ile-de-france non en gaz et pétrole de
schiste et il y aura aussi la projection
en avant première du film proma island
en vo dont matt damon est à l'origine
avec matt damon
tout à fait il sera présent aussi oui
non pas ça en espoirs en bourse et les
peut-être ce qui lui permet dommage
et donc vous n'avez 10,1 ce sera à b ce
soir 20h15 si vous me suivez en direct
vu qu il est 18h dépêchez-vous merci
julie pour ce point sur l'environnement
on va terminer cette chronique juste
avec un dernier reportage une opération
citoyenne de saison oui c'est le
nettoyage de printemps qui a débuté donc
on est allé voir ce week-end avec
anthony rech
ce qui se passait du côté de saint rémy
les chevreuse à l'initiative du parc
naturel régional de la haute vallée de
chevreuse
ce dimanche des chinois éco citoyen ou
d'investisseurs rémy les chevreuse ou la
plupart venaient pour la première fois
les membres de l'association des jeunes
chinois de france sont arrivés de toute
la région pour ramasser les déchets
abandonnés depuis l'espace racines
jusqu'à la réserve naturelle près du
château de vaux génie aidé d'une famille
de saint rémois tous munis de gants et
de sacs plastiques colorés pour le tri
sélectif cas de tous via du verre il y
avait beaucoup de canettes beaucoup de
plastique beaucoup de bars est un peu
comme ça là où de restauration rapide et
georgette
on trouve beaucoup de déchets le long
des routes et puis même dans
nature afin d'endiguer ce fléau la ville
s'inscrit dans un programme lancé par le
parc naturel régional de la haute vallée
de chevreuse programme appelé nettoyage
de printemps
l'autre méthode pour faire évoluer les
comportements sensibiliser les plus
jeunes ainsi les groupes scolaires de
saint rémy les chevreuse ont adopté des
arbres fruitiers
chaque école aujourd'hui travaillent sur
la découverte donc de l'environnement à
travers la plantation de ces arbres de
fruitiers sur la préservation aussi de
tous pliés environnement espaces verts
jardins parfois les enfants sont déjà
éduqué au respect de la nature comme
cette participante de 10 ans très
impliqué ce dimanche
franchement les déchets il ya des
poubelles un peu partout en compte et
les jeter donc quel message toi tu
aimerais faire passer aujourd'hui
ok c'est pas enfin on n'a pas besoin de
les jeter partout parce que on a juste à
faire quelques pas pour les jeter dans
une poubelle et c'est bon pour la nature
chaque année sur la commune 12 mètres
cubes de déchets sont ramassés puis mené
à la déchetterie
prochaines dates de ramassage le 6 avril
à chevreuse et magny les hameaux